Here's the original circle we had with a radius of 50 and its center was at the
origin 0,0. We want to have a new circle at center negative 10 comma 20. So we
really need to move our circle 10 units left and 20 units up. This means in the
equation we'll see a plus 10 next to the x. And a minus 20 next to the y. The
positive 10 will shift our circle 10 units to the left, and we see that here.
And the minus 20 will shift our circle 20 units up vertically. Notice too that
the signs here are opposite. If we have a circle with a center at negative 10,
then in the equation we have positive 10 next to the x. And if the center is at
positive 20 for the y coordinate, then we have negative 20 in the equation. If
you feel like you're stuck, try creating some other circles with other numbers
and see how the circles move. Are you moving up, down, left, or right?